merck hat ein video herausgebracht in
dem er seine meinung zu schulen sagt
ganz wichtig hierbei ist allerdings das
hat keine meinung ist ich weiß den
meisten von euch ist es bestimmt bewusst
trotzdem kann man sich oft genug
wiederholen
hass ist keine meinung ich möchte in
diesem video eigentlich zu sehr auf mehr
als argumente eingehen denn die sind so
schlecht dass man am liebsten seinen
kopf gegen die wand hauen würde doch ein
argument von ihm lässt mich nicht los
und zwar das schwulsein nicht natürlich
ist und dazu muss ich sagen
doch wer ist es wir als menschen sind
teil der natur und auch bei uns immer
mehr von ihr verabschieden und nicht
mehr ganz so zu wertschätzen wissen
wurden wir von dieser natur über
tausende von jahren erschaffen also so
wie wir heute sind ein produkt der natur
ein wichtiger teil dieses produkt ist
und von ziemlich vielen anderen
lebewesen ist die sexualität und ja
diese sind eigentlich dafür und mit
fortzupflanzen
das ist richtig aber die natur möchte
auch dass sich gleichgeschlechtliche
paare finden und dass ein mann ein mann
und eine frau eine frau lieben kam und
da muss man nicht hinterfragen was die
natur sich dabei gedacht hat nur wenn
man es selber nicht fühlt oder
nachvollziehen kann denn fakt ist es ist
möglich und das ist wunderschön und es
ist verdammt noch mal
natürlich man könnte eigentlich mitleid
bewährt haben denn wer so viel hass
verbreitet kann noch nicht richtige
liebe gespült haben gleich haben seine
eltern gingen im dönerladen richtig zeit
für ihn wir wissen es mich aber
definitiv keine entschuldigung doch bei
all dem hat sollte man niemals vergessen
wie schön die liebe ist verliebt zu sein
oder einen anderen menschen zu lieben
ist das schönste was sie passieren kann
und es geht nicht um mann und frau oder
männer die männer lieben es geht um das
gefühl dass ich habe wenn ja meine
geschwister denke wenn ich an meine
beste freundin denke ich kann mit stolz
sagen dass ich sie liebe ich würde
niemals ausschließen dass ich mich nicht
auch in eine frau verlieben kann und mit
ihr zusammen sein möchte
denn es ist okay und es gibt nichts
wovor man sich fürchten muss für mich
zählt nur ob es dann eine liebe ist oder
nicht mich macht der gedanke unfassbar
traurig dass es da draußen menschen gibt
die so sexualität verstecken müssen
wollen weil es immer noch idioten wie
einen wert gibt die nicht akzeptieren
wollen dass nicht jeder gleich ist ich
weiß nicht mit diesem video keine neue
erkenntnisse schaffen werde und dass sie
auch nicht in den köpfen von mert
unverändert
aber es war mir wichtig einfach mal zu
sagen dass es okay ist und das erleben
dürft wenn ihr wollt dass eure
sexualität nur euch interessieren sollte
und dass jeder mensch gut ist so wie er
ist ausser wenn du meinst verbreiten zu
müssen dann bist du kein guter mensch
dann bist du mein ziemlich alles ein
bisschen